quando ho avuto il menarca
Ho scoperto un nuovo incredibile
desiderio quello della menopausa
potrà sembrare incredibile e assurdo e
ad oggi anche a me da questa impressione
ma nel momento in cui finalmente sono
arrivate le tanto attese mestruazioni e
mia mamma urlava per casa Sei diventata
una signorina Io ero in bagno a
contorcermi dal dolore
quell'anno ho avuto le mestruazioni tre
volte che coincide con il numero di
accessi in pronto soccorso che sono
stato obbligata a fare perché per me
mestruazioni oltre al sangue significava
svenimenti vomito
dolori indicibili che mi obbligavano per
giorni e giorni a letto
dopo un paio di anni ho scoperto che mia
mamma aveva il cancro e così per
svagarmi mi ha mandato in vacanza con il
mio fidanzatino dell'epoca io avevo 16
anni e durante quella vacanza
c'è stato l'inizio della fine un vero e
proprio incubo Ma io allora non lo
sapevo ancora ho avuto il mio primo
episodio di cistite
fortunatamente quella che in quel
momento mi è sembrata una fortuna il
papà del mio fidanzatino era un medico
quando gli ho raccontato i miei sintomi
mi ha prescritto l'antibiotico e mi ha
mandato in farmacia io Ero felicissima
finalmente non dovevo più andare in
ospedale non dovevo sentirmi dire che il
mio dolore non era vero che era un po'
stressata che mi lamentavo che avevo una
soglia del dolore bassa bastava una
ricetta bianca e due bustine da assumere
la sera prima di andare a dormire
E così è stato quando sono tornata da
quella vacanza Ho avuto un altro
episodio di cistite e poi un altro e poi
un altro e poi un altro per otto anni mi
sono sentita dire che non avevo
assolutamente nulla che ero
perfettamente sana tanto che quel dolore
Era diventato Giorgia Giorgia e il
dolore eravamo Un'unica cosa ed è stato
il mio compagno più devoto
nel momento in cui è iniziato il
lockdown io non potevo più nascondere il
mio dolore e quelle viscere che
bruciavano come se stessi andando a
fuoco e la disperazione Mi ha fatto fare
una cosa che solitamente estremamente
sconsigliata e cioè cercare i propri
sintomi online
passavo le nottate seduta in bagno il
dolore Era talmente forte da avere i
graffi sulle cosce perché mentre urinavo
mi faceva un male incredibile mi veniva
la febbre mi veniva la pelle d'oca e
passavo queste nottate urinando sangue e
cercando i sintomi nel digitavo uno e
guardavo le prime 10 pagine nel digita
un altro e guardavo le prime 10 pagine
così sono approdata sul sito di
un'associazione
e ho letto per la prima volta la parola
vulvodinia vulvo che vi chiederete E
questa era stata la mia reazione
all'epoca esistevano a dir tanto cinque
risultati su Google in italiano legati
alla vulvodinia E così ho iniziato a
leggere a leggere le testimonianze di
altri pazienti e mi riconoscevo in ogni
sintomo in ogni storia in ogni
esperienza e quindi ho fatto il percorso
contrario al posto di avere un dolore
andare dal medico e avere una diagnosi
ho conosciuto la malattia ho cercato Un
Medico in grado di fare una diagnosi e
soprattutto di darmi una terapia e così
è stato dopo otto lunghi anni ho
finalmente ricevuto la mia diagnosi di
vulvodinia
per la maggior parte delle persone il
momento della diagnosi è un momento
triste doloroso spaventoso per me è
stata la liberazione più grande della
mia vita Non avevo mai provato
un'emozione tanto potente sono uscita mi
sono seduta in macchina vicino a mia
mamma e ho iniziato a piangere come una
bambina e dire avevo ragione io quel
dolore aveva un nome dare un nome alle
cose Importantissimo perché il
linguaggio crea realtà ci permette di
dare uno spazio concreto al nostro
dolore tramite un nome se noi non
avessimo un nome non potremmo essere
chiamati e così ho fatto anche per tutte
le altre malattie neurofatiche del
pudendo endometriosi adenomiosi
quando sono stata
in ospedale la prima volta in cui ho
detto forse endometriosi mi riconosco in
tutti i sintomi Avevo vent'anni mi è
stato detto che ero ipocondriaca che
dovevo rilassarmi quando ho raccontato
che avere rapporti mi provocava dolore
mi è stato detto che era normale Io sono
uscita da quello studio chiedendomi Ma
perché sei normale piace così tanto a
tutti o viviamo in un Truman Show o
qualcosa non mi torna
nel momento in cui ho avuto la diagnosi
avevo circa 100 mila follower ho detto
se posso aiutare un'altra persona
a ricevere una diagnosi dare un nome al
proprio dolore allora senso raccontarlo
si è aperto un vaso di Pandora Io ho
scoperto chi divulgo di mia Ne soffre
una donna su 7 di endometriosi una su 10
Solo in Italia Con diagnosi conclamata
sono più di 3 milioni di donne e in
ritardo Un medio diagnostico è di 7-10
anni
E così ho iniziato a condividere a
condividere la mia esperienza a
condividere la mia storia a condividere
il mio dolore a far capire alle persone
Cosa significa vivere con una malattia
cronica perché purtroppo sono tutte
malattie croniche queste
e nel momento in cui io cercavo di
aiutare gli altri mi rendevo conto che
gli altri aiutavano me
c'è stato un
importantissimo artista che è mancato da
poco Salvatore iaconesi che tra l'altro
ha parlato diversi Ted e ha creato
questa performance che si chiamava la
cura a 39 anni gli è stato diagnosticato
un cancro al cervello e ha deciso di
condividere online la sua diagnosi e la
sua cartella clinica per essere aiutato
questo rende la malattia un fatto
collettivo e la cura come diceva lui è
molto diversa dalla terapia
E mentre mi raccontavo e gli altri si
raccontavano a me mi rendevo conto che
più imparavo a conoscere il mio dolore e
più non lo volevo combattere ma lo
volevo semplicemente accogliere Volevo
avere tenerezza di me e questo mi ha
fatto capire che i limiti sono
importantissimi e sono importanti perché
spesso ci vengono fatti passare come una
cosa negativa devi andare oltre i tuoi
limiti ma secondo me la vera magia è
abbracciarli accoglierli
e finalmente imparare in qualche modo ad
amarli
Grazie davvero grazie
[Applauso]